the function G is defined over the real
numbers this table gives select values
of G what is a reasonable estimate for
the limit as X approaches 5 of G of X so
pause this video look at this table it
gives us the X values as we approach 5
from values less than 5 and as we
approach 5 from values greater than 5 it
even tells us what G of X is at x equals
5 and so given that what is a reasonable
estimate for this limit all right now
let's work through this together so
let's think about what G of X seems to
be approaching as X approaches 5 from
values less than 5 let's see it 4 is at
3 point 3 7 4 point 9 it's a little
higher 23.54.99 three point six six four
point nine nine nine so very close to 5
or only a thousandth away we're at three
point six eight but then at five all of
a sudden we it looks like we're kind of
jumping to six point three seven once
again I'm I'm making an inference here I
don't these are just sample points of
this function we don't know exactly what
the function is but then if we approach
five from values greater than five at 6
or at three point nine seven at five
point one root three point eight four
five point zero one three point seven
five point zero zero one we are at three
point six eight so a thousandth below
five and a thousand above five were at
three point six eight but then at five
also at six point three seven so my most
reasonable estimate would be well it
looks like we are approaching three
point six eight when we are approaching
from values less than five and we're
approaching three point six eight from
values as we approach five from values
greater than five it doesn't matter that
the value of five is six point three
seven the limit would be three point six
eight or a reasonable estimate for the
limit would be three point six eight and
this is probably the most tempting
distractor here because if you were to
just substitute 550 what is G of 5 it
tells us six point three seven but the
limit does not have to be what the
actual function equals at that point
I'll let me draw what this might look
like and so an example of this so if
this is five right over here at the
point five the value of my function is
six point two
3:7 so let's say that this right over
here is 6.37
so that's the value of my function right
over there so six point three seven but
as we approach five so that's four
actually let me spread out a little bit
this obviously is not drawing scale but
as we approach five so this is that's
six point three seven
then at four three point three seven is
about here and it looks like it's
approaching three point six eight so
three point six eight X let me draw that
so three point six eight is going to be
roughly that three point six eight could
be roughly that so the graph the graph
looks might look something like this we
could infer it looks like it's doing
something like this where it's
approaching three point six eight from
values less than five and values greater
than five but right at five our values
six point three seven I don't know for
sure if this is what the graph looks
like once again we're just getting some
sample points but this would be a
reasonable inference and so you can see
our limit we are approaching three point
six eight even though the value of the
function is something different